do you work in a creative place maybe
you're a filmmaker or an author perhaps
you're an artist or an actress maybe
you're an app designer with a low down
whichever cultural or creative sector
you work in the European Union can help
and that's where creative Europe gets
going
creative Europe offers people like you
yes people just like you the chance to
gain funding and support for your
projects
this would mean working with partners in
other countries support could come in
the form of training or it could be
audience development yes
creative Europe can help you tap into an
audience of more than 500 million EU
citizens not to mention billions more
around the world are you ready for a new
opportunity then make sure you get
involved how does it work
once there were three programs for
applying to this sort of thing but to
save you from getting tied up in knots
there's now the one-stop-shop creative
Europe not only that but we've reduced
the paperwork for applicants so the
process is quicker and easier to top it
all the total funding has increased to
more than 1.4 billion euro but you might
be wondering what this means for you
well say you want to train your team to
switch to digital technologies we're
there
if you're looking to increase your
audience we're there - yes
creative Europe can support marketing
and circulation of work of cross borders
in film alone it would take several
months of non-stop viewing to watch all
the features expected to be distributed
with this funding if films not your
thing it could be an animation video
game work of fiction or concert we help
you get off the ground maybe you want to
get a successful novel translated so
readers across Europe can enjoy it in
their own language
after all creative Europe plans to
translate over 4,500 literary works or
you might be more interested in shining
a light on the original creative Europe
runs prestigious awards to draw new
audiences to the best creative talent in
architecture music cultural heritage
literature and filmmaking even cities
can battle it out for an award on the
European scene and each year we award
the title of European Capital of Culture
to two cities and the best thing about
creative Europe we fund projects of all
sorts of sizes involving any cultural
and creative sector it doesn't matter
whether you're a two-man organization or
one with a thousand members you can all
benefit from creative Europe are you
ready for a new challenge with so much
to offer there's bound to be something
in it for you to find out more visit
EcoP you forward slash creative - Europe
or join the conversation on Twitter
you